[Music]
you and I will go nanotechnology man
I'll take we'll get inside their
bloodstream with our tiny machines and
then we'll help I love that idea
oh my goodness
you know I'd say you look a little bit
like Robotnik but I could be projecting
that I am you but you are me at my full
potential of madness yes well that's
true but you know you never could finish
me because of this blue little thingy
Sonic
so my systems you know what your problem
is your problem is you have a sonic
shaped hole in your heart
I recognize you from from my movie that
is true I am the masterpiece of dr.
Robotnik
I am dr. Robotnik 2.0 but he could never
finish me and complete me because of
this little guy huh so who is this Sonic
and why does everybody loves him sign is
one of the most influential video game
characters I think of all time
certainly to me as a 13 year old when I
first played the game I just loved the
character love the attitude love the
speed of the game and to be able to take
that character and tell a movie do a
movie and tell a story with him was just
the chance of a lifetime and I think
audiences are in for an amazing
experience
mister dr. Robotnik yes I am Master do
we actually have a job description to
operate with probity and precipitation
you know it's just get everything own
everything
that's everything outside people and
inside people eventually you and I you
and I will go nanotechnology man I'll
take we'll get inside their bloodstream
with our tiny machines and then we'll
help them I love that idea
just let me be clear you are a friend of
sonic right I know him very well
hmm and you know my master dr. Robotnik
- I do oh here they have here they have
some differences of opinion Thanks I
don't get along so well why do you think
it's that so oh because he's usually
firing weapons at him and chasing him
around it's usually a sign of conflict
why do we hate sonic because sonic
represents innocence and childlike
electric play blah all those things that
we never did gusting yeah you remember
when we were inside the lab looking out
the window I'm watching the children
play team sports
go ahead that we ate I mean the closest
we could ever get his goaltender but
that's not really part of a team is it
no yeah what do you think about my boss
isn't he wonderful he's the great I mean
aside from all the villainy and the
threat of world domination I feel like
he's he's actually really he's a
wonderful guy at least the the actor
that plays in Jim Carrey is immortal so
I updated our friends list and it's
empty why because friendless means
friendless
that's right this think about that for a
while yeah
Mull that over okay I think Rabbani
would probably like a friend I think
that's the real that's the real problem
is he's after human connection so do we
have any do and don'ts why being the
best doctor robotnik is using don'ts yes
brushing your teeth optional do love
your machines with your whole heart I
mean just madly take over every aspect
of life not only make a new product or a
new machine but legislate it into
people's lives don't be nice to agent
stone you're your right-hand man it's
not good enough that we offer them
self-driving cars
eventually we get to take the steering
wheel away I like that idea and we get
to tell them where to dry do do
everything you can to stop Sonic from
living a fun free life yeah those are
the ones that come to mind and if they
have a park outstanding parking tickets
we take them right to the police station
or we can ultimately control them that
sounds very good since you were busy
with Sonic I took another enemy of us
here's Olaf Olivia you can open it
really can i yeah nothing happens gonna
happen
ice happened to some guy in North Korea
know if I want to break the seal on this
thing I'll hold my breath
didn't pop out okay of course and see
what else empty jar what a great idea
it's a em enemy of us
I gave him mushroom he could not digest
oh man yeah so this guy is getting
awkward oh yes you did that for me yeah
oh thank you man that's wonderful and so
good to have the doppelganger so you
don't have to worry about this character
anymore
Wow that's dark yeah we can't we all
just get along
always wonderful little game characters
so good do you put them on sticks like
butterflies before wonderful what style
do you like better this one or this one
that's more facial you know I think that
you know this is that mustache is the
zygote of the later version so you know
truly like a fetus if allowed to grow it
will take over the world yes it's it's
the mustache that says I've just tied a
woman to the railroad tracks for no
reason
ah don't make me choose I think they're
both fantastic thank you very much I
appreciate the effort today thank you
thanks you're amazing yeah you got an
actual bald cap as well this is my god
that's fantastic there thank you doctor
rates just a robotic doctor robot great
system you made me like this way I found
something in our laboratory oh yes and I
don't know still what it is for I know
really
quickly and throw it to an assistant
[Laughter]
just like diesel it's all about family
Tom Sonic the Hedgehog
[Music]